bom pessoal é quando eu fui me informar
quando estava me formar no colegial
eu sou filha única e aí rolou uma
pressão na minha casa porque meu pai
queria que eu fizesse direito quer a
carreira da família dele e que direito é
uma carreira muito tradicional filha
a minha mãe queria que fizesse uma água
que desce emprego filho atenção com as
pessoas precisem entendeu e para ela
todo mundo está aprendendo vai ser
professora olha que ótimo e eu queria
fazer moda então a gente não se entendia
muito na minha casa e como todo mundo é
as expectativas dos pais são muito
fortes em cima da gente é e eu era filha
única ela não sou né
e é isso acabou que não tinha ninguém
pra compartilhar essas expectativas
e essa é a história que vou contar pra
vocês e aí como como foi toda essa
tomada de decisão
eu cá vem prestando três cursos eu sabia
que era humanas um negócio e eu acabei
vencendo três cursos e acabei vencendo
relações públicas é direito e pedagogia
aí eu passei relações públicas pedagogia
e por uma questão familiar e acaba indo
para pedagogia
chegando lá eu vi que não era pra mim 30
crianças ao mesmo tempo num lugar
fechado de verdade por mais que eu gosto
de criança eu gosto é tem que amar e aí
a amar não era eu eu falei eu não amo
tanto assim eu gosto de criança uma por
vez de preferência
e aí quando eu vi 30 eu falei agora eu
preciso fazer alguma coisa e aí eu
comecei a procurar e aí o preço a ser
uma estratégia pra como eu vou reverter
essa situação foi o de cursinho para
prestar vestibular de novo fui tentar a
transferência na universidade estudei
aqui na ufscar e também foi procurar o
que dentro da pedagogia eu podia fazer e
aí procurando procurando procurando
achei a área de recursos humanos que é
bom pode ser que seja um pouco a minha
cara e aí vou contar pra vocês agora
quais foram os passos que eu seguir para
conseguir formar em uma coisa e
trabalhar em outro
então o primeiro passo
parecer muito bobo é você descobrir qual
é a sua marca porque é eu sempre fui
muito tímida por incrível que isso possa
parecer é e aí eu era daquelas crianças
que tinha um amigo no colégio e quando
ele faltava como lanche sozinha não era
legal
aí eu não sei o que aconteceu e qual foi
o meu ponto de mudança no nome no
colegial já comecei a ficar mais
introvertida e na graduação eu me tornei
isso que eu sou hoje muito extrovertida
e aí eu fiquei pensando que eu ia fazer
com isso neto não saber que era muito
introvertido as minhas amigas falavam
das relações públicas do grupo vai lá e
resolve pra gente então não tinha
problema de falar com as pessoas falar
com gente que eu não conhecia me esforço
pra mim não era problema então sempre
era eu a escolhida para falar com alguém
então essa é a minha marca
e aí como é que você faz para descobrir
a sua marca
pergunta das pessoas pensa também em
quando que você acionado então quando é
que você e seus amigos lembra de você
que a sua família lembra de você
resolver um problema é que a se
organizar a organizar alguma coisa
planejar é quando trata de cid números
de finanças tão tensa cola quando é que
isso é você acionado as pessoas lembram
de você pra mim era conversar com as
pessoas que consigam ir pra festa na
faculdade mas é você pode ter outra
marca então isso é um ponto muito
importante se conhecer e descobrir o que
você tem de especial assim é muito
relevante isso nessa nessa transição que
quem quiser fazer uma transição de
carreira e aí ok descobrirem a marca
tipo confesso com todo mundo olha que
legal
tá mas como ela vira uma profissão né
porque ao lado dois ali como eu sou uma
pessoa cara de pau
eu acabei me valendo disso para
conseguir descobrir o segundo passo é o
meu segundo passo foi é e eu conversava
com todo o mundo sobre carreira
então eu aquela vizinha que eu nunca
tinha conversado na vida que eu pegar o
elevador só falava o bom dia boa tarde
boa noite eu tenho um papel que você faz
que precisa fazer o que você faz
então comecei a perguntar da rotina das
pessoas então todo mundo entrou na dança
na pizza na casa de um amigo já
apresentava principais é o que você faz
aí é legal precisa pra fazer o que você
faz
então comecei a ver o que a habilidade
das pessoas tinham para fazer as coisas
que elas faziam outra coisa que também
foi bem importante obviamente que eu me
formei há 13 anos e na época tinha muito
menos do que a gente tem hoje eram
vídeos textos e histórias de
empreendedores gente que fez mudança de
carreira outra coisa que também foi
importante pra mim foi entender um pouco
é pessoas que tinham feito ligações de
carreira muito muito distantes e também
para quem tem oportunidade ainda está na
faculdade até mesmo para quem não tá é
vale muito você e tentando dar uma táti
ada na área que você se interessa então
por exemplo você faz engenharia mental e
quer trabalhar com finanças como eu vou
saber se é finanças mesmo que eu quero
ou não muito simples você pode
apresentar um trabalho voluntário e você
ser responsável pelo caixa e aí você
começa a devagar a entrar naquela área e
vênus que aquilo faz sentido para você
ou não vai tudo à chuva empresa júnior
vale comissão de formatura também é
muito legal é então lembrem disso e
comecem a dar pequenos passos na sua
área de opção e não nas áreas de
graduação é uma outra outro passo eu
acho que foi pra mim foi crucial na
verdade foi fazer um curso livre que é
um curso livre é todo custo fazer uma
pós graduação têm como requisito uma
graduação certo é um curso livre é um
curso que não tem um requisito
então você vai quem costuma da aula são
profissionais da área e eles pegam a
macro hora que você tem interesse fáçil
e cada um módulo transformam a mclaren
sub-áreas e aí cada fim semana você tem
uma uma aula um tema diferente então
isso fez muita diferença para mim porque
eu tive aula com gente que estava no dia
a dia e isso faz toda a diferença
você conseguir ver a percepção das
pessoas do que além da teoria o que aqui
o que faz sentido é e
esse curso mudou muito a minha vida
porque vocês lembram eu sou a prometida
cara de pau que não tem vergonha eu
cheguei um dia no final dá uma aula era
minha professora de treinamento e
desenvolvimento é olha é o seguinte eu
preciso fazer um estágio e rh
eu queria saber se você trabalha tem
vaga aí ela falou assim para mim vai ser
humana que vem lá nal na empresa aí eu
fui
e aí vem o meu próximo passo que foi
fazer um bom estágio um bom estágio fez
toda a diferença na minha vida é o
estágio acabou me dando é a prática
melhores práticas também me trouxe é
networking eu consegui entender qual é a
tendência da minha área ainda também
conhecer um pouco do que eu gosto que eu
não gosto porque não é porque você quer
atuar numa área que você gosta da área
inteira certo então por exemplo recursos
humanos eu tenho várias áreas e tem uma
parte específica que fala de impostos
taxas e realmente aquilo não é a minha
binha maior vontade assim não é o que eu
mais me identifico então é fazer um
estágio me trouxe é esse pé no chão a
prática que eu tanto precisava e vários
super você investir em um bom estágio é
quem ainda está na graduação obviamente
então é tem hoje um monte de jeito de
você conseguir um estágio os processos
seletivos visita técnica vagas pontuais
e até um pouco de cara de pau porque não
é pra conseguir fazer um bom estágio ele
acaba tirando o rótulo que você precisa
e acho que vale um parêntese bem
importante que eu atuo em recursos
humanos e foi uma coisa que aconteceu
comigo essa migração de carreira o
mercado ele rotula a gente então o meu
voto eu queria que no começo fosse uma
pedagoga trabalho em rh hoje e ninguém
nem se lembra que o pedagogo às vezes
nem eu mesma é e hoje eu sou uma
profissional de rh
então a gente tem que buscar e pensar
muito estrategicamente em como a gente
se dá o rótulo e não o mercado não deixa
o mercado dá o voto em você
então pense nisso quando forem pensar
numa nova carreira e os passos que vocês
vão dar
não deixa o mercado voltou a vocês
busquem artifícios e estratégias para
conseguir colocar o voto que você acha
interessante pra você que vai te fazer
feliz é uma pós-graduação eu fiz uma pós
graduação em recursos humanos e eu era
recém formada e eu me lembro que após
ela foi a cereja do bolo é essa coisa do
rótulo então foi o que me deu o carimbo
final de nada assim
após gravação ela traz profundidade no
tema porque no começo você não tem é
essa questão da profundidade você passou
por puro disciplinas da graduação você
passou por curso livre você fez um
estágio mas não tem ainda profundidade
quanto ao tema e também porque ela te dá
um networking incrível na minha na minha
graduação na minha pós-graduação eu
tinha diretores gerentes de rh e eu me
lembro assim como ele estava na prática
eles eram super sênior senhor 20 e 30
anos de carreira eles tinham um nível de
pergunta que de verdade eu não sabia nem
por onde começar e quando a gente não
sabe nada do assunto a gente não sabe
nem perguntar né
e era o meu caso não sabe nem por onde
começar e ele me aprofundava uma
discussão num nível é que fazia após
vale muito a pena
fora isso o networking que você constrói
as pessoas que você começa a admirar os
cases que você vê e é um bom contraponto
o que os alunos trazem os diretores na
minha pós-graduação estavam lá é os
gerentes a parte prática do dia a dia
que eles trazem no contraponto com a
teoria que o professor traz a discussão
é como eles ampliavam o tema isso fez
muita diferença pra mim acho que pode
fazer também para quem decide seguir
esse caminho
e aí toca fez uma boa apresentação além
do tema acho que é importante obviamente
você chega financeiramente
nesta compatível com o que você pode
pagar é também dar uma olhada na agenda
porque às vezes tem alguns dias de aula
que não são compatíveis com a sua agenda
de trabalho de vida enfim é e também
olhar o
um dos alunos porque é muito importante
que as pessoas que fazem parte do seu
grupo estejam é também no mesmo no mesmo
ímpeto que você enfim e que seja um
grupo que tem alguma diversidade porque
a diversidade enriquece muito é as
discussões enfim cada um traz um ponto
de vista eu lembro que na minha
pós-graduação tinha médico economista é
cientista social psicólogo administrador
engenheiro então foi muito positivo por
conta disso
e aí vocês vão falar aretha vai pedir
paciência é é é é paciência faz parte
desse processo também de mudança de
carreira porque algumas vezes a gente
não tem uma o mesmo a mesma facilidade a
mesma rapidez de entrar na área do que
pessoas que têm um curso tradicional da
clara e aqui eu disse algumas vezes
porque nem sempre é assim é então pode
ser que demore um pouquinho mais que
isso seja um pouco mais para você você
acha que está demorando muito todo mundo
já está trabalhando eu não tô fica
tranquilo esse tempo não faz nenhuma
diferença na sua carreira ele se dilui
ao longo dos anos e isso não pesa em
nada pra você
então o importante é ter foco tem o
apoio da sua família apoio dos amigos
nesse momento que você está buscando
migrar de carreira é e buscando o rótulo
que você quer então lembra sempre disso
é muito estratégico todas as ações que
você tomar para mudar de carreira então
vai tentando ver o que é possível para
você o que te faz feliz né porque quem
prestou um curso e que a trabalhar coisa
tem a sensação que errou e o que eu acho
que ora essa sensação
a gente sempre aprende nosso curso por
mais que seja um tema que você falou meu
deus que nem eu com as crianças não têm
nada que o atleta que tem um monte de
coisa tem crianças na minha família eu
super aproveito e continuo gostando de
criança é mais uma por uma por vez né
não 30
é mais isso sempre a gente consegue
aproveitar coisas custam conhecimento
nunca é demais isso que eu acho
importante e por fim se perguntarem puxa
valeu a pena e se ter feito essa
migração ter pensado nisso o tempo que
você demorou pra ingressar na área enfim
que se acha eu acho que valeu super a
pena eu sou muito feliz na minha
carreira eu acho que a vida muito muito
curta pra gente ser feliz ótimo fim de
semana em semana são só dois dias na
gente há semanas 15 então eu quero ser
feliz de segunda a segunda então a minha
proposta para quem não está feliz com o
curso e que a mudar de carreira eu acho
que é super bahia pensa estrategicamente
eu espero que essas dicas tenham ajudado
vocês muito obrigado
[Aplausos]